[Music]
recently while speaking at an N double
ACP convention Mitt Romney brought his
own black cheering section to give the
appearance that n-double-a-cp members
were applauding him yeah it yeah it has
been a bit of a controversy for his
campaign now a lot of people are calling
his actions insensitive here to comment
is one of our writers Deon Cole died
thanks Conan MIT you brought your own
black cheering section to an N double
ACP Riley Wow who's that out of touch
with minorities that you had to hire
group of black people to clap for you
you ought to be ashamed of yourself
mister MIT Romney yeah well Deion I
could not agree with you more hiring a
group of black people to cheer for you
is the lowest form of racial pandering
[Applause]
thank you thank you and you have my word
I will never disrespect my black fans
like that
[Applause]
thank you by the way it may interest you
to know I once met Tyler Perry at an
airport
[Applause]
we got a great show from the Showtime
series weeds comedian Kevin Nealon is
here
from the ABC Family series Pretty Little
Liars Ashley banks is on the Sarah
comedian Beth Stelling is here
and of course our own Andy rector
[Applause]
you